do I have a history that predisposes me
to a certain thing yes that just means
it's harder for you to do what you need
to do but it is still up to you the past
is over the future hasn't happened yet
the only time is right now and the only
question is what are you gonna do
[Music]
hello and welcome this is the Sunday
special with dr. Phil McGraw the host of
the dr. Phil show in the brand-new
podcast
fill in the blanks we'll get to our
interview with dr. Phil in just one
second but first let's talk about the
post office no one really has time to go
to the post office you are busy who's
got the time for all that traffic
parking lugging all your mail and
packages no joke last time I went to the
post office I got a parking ticket this
is why you need stamps calm it's one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses stamps calm eliminates
trips to the post office and saves you
money with discounts you can't even get
at the post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service direct
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices or an online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in mailbox it is indeed that
simple and with stamps comm you get five
cents off every first-class stampin up
to 40% off Priority Mail not to mention
it's a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters stamps a comes
a no-brainer it'll save you time it will
save you money which is why over 700
thousand small businesses already use
stamps calm right now our listeners get
a special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
Shapiro that stamps comm click on that
mic at the top of the homepage type in
Shapiro for the special deal well dr.
Phil thanks so much for stopping by not
sure why you're slumming it with us but
I'm glad you glad you made it
listen nice digs you got here I
appreciate it and your your solid liar
yeah I can only tell because I've been
watching your show and you've told me
how to spot a liar I need to stop doing
that people can pick it out now it's
dangerous so let's start from the very
beginning for folks who don't know your
story how did you become the dr. Phil
that is a household name everybody knows
he are how did you go from point A to
point B well Oprah has a big part of
this there would be no dr. Phil without
Oprah of course and I I was working as a
trial consultant I had a trial science
firm in Dallas called courtroom Sciences
and I represented Oprah as part of her
trial team in the mad cow case people
might remember the mad cow case up in
Amarillo
she was sued by the
cattle growers people think is a bunch
of ranchers not bunch of ranchers a
bunch of cattle growers I mean these are
was hundred thousand cows in a feedlot
she made a comment that they alleged
disparaged her about beef and suit her
in Amarillo and that's behind enemy
lines for her so I helped defend her in
that case up there and after that she
asked me to be on her show and after a
while I did and then she asked me to be
on again and then again and again and
then I started doing every Tuesday for
five years and from that came the dr.
Phil show and I'm now in my seventeenth
season I never intended to be on
television at all in fact in all the
years that I worked as a trial scientist
I never gave one interview not one time
you know people would come to trial and
say you know who are you answer was
always the same I'm not here because we
didn't want to be in the spotlight then
we're going to be behind the scenes so
it's never my aspiration to do it but I
really enjoyed doing her show and then
sprang the dr. Phil and now as I say
we're in our 17th season coming up on
3,000 shows and 20,000 guests and here
we are well one of the things that
obviously you're famous for is your
ability to read other human beings and a
lot of your show is the personal
interaction that you have with other
folks how accurate do you think that
people can actually be just by talking
to folks about assessing where they're
coming from whether they're lying that
that sort of thing well you know would
you really sit down and focus on
somebody and particularly the people
that I work with I think they really
come in wanting me to know the truth and
we really manage people's expectations
first off I don't work with anybody that
doesn't want to work with me I mean I
don't stop cars out on sunset and say
you look like you need help get out
that's not how it works I mean we get
tens of thousands of emails of people
wanting to be there and and it's hard to
get there because I mean somebody told
me other day
the average guest is written in 20 or 30
times before they get there which I hate
I'm sorry about that but they really
want to be there and I make it real
clear look I can help you with anything
you tell me about even if it's to tell
you I can't help you or I will send you
where you can get help but if you come
in and tell me something that's not the
truth if you're just coming in trying to
cover your ass or spin this you're
wasting my time in yours so you worked
really hard to get here so you need to
tell me the truth so most people really
are trying to put it out there and tell
me the truth and if they're not it's
pretty obvious if somebody's they're
just trying to be a right fighter not on
their part of a circumstance or
situation when it's a family issue or
they're on drugs or whatever if they're
trying to evade and hide it's pretty
evident because they're not wanting to
take accountability or whatever and once
they start getting honest that's real
clear too but most of the people come in
are trying to really get some help
sincerely or they don't make the cut
because we do every guest that I deal
with I get a notebook it's probably 250
pages thick because we do intake
interview I do a cross-sectional history
a longitudinal history a medical history
a social history we interview
collaterals neighbors friends family
members to try to get as many
perspectives as we possibly can so I
have a lot of information that doesn't
just come from them and then I have an
advisory board for dr. Phil and that's
made up of the top minds in psychology
psychiatry medicine sociology and
they're from the top learning centers in
the country
I've got the head of the Family Division
in the Harvard Medical School here the
children the child psychiatry at Yale
University I've got dr. Zimbardo
professor emeritus from Stanford
University that's done all but remember
he did the Prison Experiment
there's written most of the general
sike textbooks if people went through
general psych they probably had Zimbardo
as a textbook I've just got you know
that really that these are a lot of the
editors of the peer-reviewed journals in
psychology these are all on my advisory
board so if I get a really complex case
I can send it out to these different men
and women on my advisory board and get
really good input from them you know
there's about an 18 to 24 months lag
time from research that's accepted for
these peer journals to the time it gets
to publish gets published so I get
beyond cutting-edge information form I
guess so we really do our homework so
what do you think are some of the
benefits and drawbacks of dealing with
people on a psychological level in
public like this well first off you have
to you have to be real clear in your
expectations of what you're gonna do I
am 100% clear with myself that I'm not
up there doing 30 minute cures I mean
come on yeah I mean people ask me
sometimes you know dr. field our
problems really as simple as you make
them out to be
I don't think problems are simple at all
in fact I think problems are often very
complex but I think the solutions are
often very simple you can have a complex
problem that maybe is generational
through someone's family history or it
may be a problem of comorbidity where
there's drugs and then there are
psychological issues and then familial
issues or are lots of things that are
feeding in to define a problem that's
multifaceted but the solution to that
problem may be very simple such as stop
doing drugs get the toxic people out of
your life hit the reset button and start
behaving your way to success and I'm
gonna give you the resources to do that
I'm gonna get you a life coach I'm gonna
get you a rehab center to get you detox
from these drugs with medical
supervision and we're gonna bring a
family counselor in to start redefining
what you call
a family dynamic so you know after 17
years I've got a network of resources
we've just passed 30 million dollars in
aftercare resources that we share with
our guests off camera away from the show
where they actually do the work so I
don't think I'm solving these people's
problems sometimes we do sometimes it's
very simple but I think of it as being
kind of an emotional compass I can tell
you what I think points you in the right
direction and then help you with the
resources you need to get there and
every guest is a teaching tool so like
you might come on the show and be a real
hammerhead just as an example example
and maybe you don't get it maybe what
I'm telling you you don't get but
sometimes the hardest most hard-headed
guests are the best teaching tools
because then I'll get thousands of
letters and they say oh my god what a
hard hit he didn't get it but I did I
heard him saying things I've said before
and I will never say that again oh my
god so they're great teaching tools even
though they don't get it so and is it a
problem doing it in public for some
people if so they wouldn't be there I
mean they choose to come and you know
there's a certain percent of the people
that are just exhibitionistic in their
personality any Lissa's faces they just
they want the attention they want to do
it in front of a camera well we have a
narcissistic society some people just
want to be in the spotlight and then
there's a percentage of the people that
they just uniquely want my perspective
they think he tells I'm tired of going
to a psychologist at Pat's me on the
hand says gonna be okay and how does it
make you feel they want somebody puts
verbs in their sentences and cuts to the
chase so they they come because they
uniquely feel like they've been in their
living room every day for 15 years they
trust me and want to know my point of
view and then there are some people that
are there because their spouse grabbed
him by the year and said get your ass
down here or I'm leaving
you know so they're they're captive
audience so they come from all walks of
life it seems like a lot of your brand
and a lot of your popularity is linked
to the fact that you're a very big
advocate of personal responsibility from
from the shows that I've seen a lot of
what happens people come in they don't
want to take responsibility for what's
going on in their life they don't want
to take responsibility for their choices
and you you kind of tell them that they
need to take responsibility for those
choices do you think that that's has
that been successful typically I mean it
sounds like your follow-up resources and
also have you gotten blowback for
pushing that hard on sort of the
personal responsibility angle well look
I don't make the rules I'm just telling
them what they are
I mean look there are some things that
I'm one of people that believes old
sayings get to be old sayings because
they're profound like a stitch in time
saves nine you know I mean these things
stick around generation to generation
generation because they apply and I have
certain rules like you just don't reward
bad behavior
I mean lassie can figure this out you
don't need to come to me for that but
sometimes they're so close to it they do
you don't reward bad behavior if
somebody comes in and they says I got a
30 year old son that's on drugs he's
living in my house he's telling me I'm a
she won't clean up his room and I can't
get him to do what I need to do whoa why
are you letting him live with you
why are you buy him a new cell phone why
are you paying all of this car payment
and insurance and he's calling you I
mean to me that just seems simple you're
rewarding bad behavior and then you're
asking me why he does it why wouldn't he
do it you're requiring nothing of him so
of course he's going to do that that
you're you know some words get so
overused they lose their meaning like
enabling you say oh well you're an
enabler people don't really stop and
think what that really means it's used
so much it loses its meaning
enable means I'm making it possible for
him to do what he's doing and if I stop
making it easy for him to do what he's
doing then again old saying necessity is
mother of invention if he has to find a
new way to live then he'll find a new
way to live I mean so I think sometimes
when I I'll set a parent down and say
look let's face it you're doing what
you're doing to make yourself feel
better not to make your attic child
healthier because it's not making your
attic child healthier you're actually
doing this so you're not anxious about
them being on the street so don't kid
yourself you're doing this to help them
you're doing this so you don't well you
play awake at night you would rather
enable them and have them high in their
bedroom then worry about them being on
the street so you're doing this for you
not them you're being selfish and you're
crippling them at their expense to make
yourself feel better yep they don't want
to hear that but is there any other way
to see it
and so I tell them the truth and usually
once they wrap their head around that
then they say I never thought of it that
way
and they change what they're doing well
I'm just a second I only asked you about
have that kind of personal
responsibility ethos meshes with a
society that may be promoting the idea
that we are all sort of subject to
forces beyond our own control but first
when the founders crafted the
Constitution the very first thing they
did was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share ideas without
limitation by the government the second
thing they enumerated was the right of
the population to protect that speech
and their own persons with force you
know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility and
building rifles is no different BCM
Bravo Company manufacturing they were
started in a garage by a Marine veteran
more than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment they
assume that every rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen a law
enforcement officer or a soldier
oversees every component of a BCM rifle
is hand assembled and tested by
Americans to a life-saving standard
Beast
works with leading instructors of
marksmanship from top levels of
America's Special Ops forces who can
teach the skills necessary to defend
yourself your family or others to learn
more about Bravo company manufacturing
head on over to Bravo Company MFG comm
you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that is Bravo Company MFG comm need
more convincing find out even more about
BCM and the awesome people who make
their products at youtube.com slash
bravo company USA so I want to ask you a
little bit about the kind of I know you
don't talk politics very much your show
is a political but I'm not sure this is
really a political question as much as
it is a societal values question that
may have some political ramifications it
seems like we live in a time where a lot
of folks want to blame their personal
behavior on forces beyond their control
they want to say that that choices that
are obviously within their control are
obviously not within their control that
they're the result of historical forces
or forces out there in the ether or
institutional pressures or or all the
rest do you see that conflict right now
in the country between between sort of
an ethos of personal responsibility and
and a system of thought that says that
you're really a victim of circumstance I
do but I don't think that it is all or
none and I look at it that way I can use
genetics as a good example my father was
a bad alcoholic we've really bad
alcoholic I mean he would drink to the
point of blackout oblivion violence
tearing up the house attacking family
members etc etc now I am genetically
predisposed to be an alcoholic
that doesn't genetics often times don't
tell you who is going to be a certain
way it just tells you who is more likely
to be a certain way it just means for me
I have a steeper Hill decline it just
means for me that I have a bigger
challenge because of historical events
learning history it nature nurture
controversy for me it was both that was
my modelling from the most
for role model in my life which was my
father genetics because my father had
the gene and passed it on to me so do I
have a history that predisposes me to a
certain thing yes the choice is still
mine I still have to make that choice
and I can still make the choices I
haven't had a drink in over 50 years
I made the choice was it harder for me
to make than somebody that wasn't
genetically predisposed yes it was
harder for me but I still have to make
it and if you have a historical
precedent that puts you at a
disadvantage okay I can understand that
argument that just means it's harder for
you to do what you need to do but it is
still up to you because you can't not
even God can change what has happened
the past is over the future hasn't
happened yet the only time is right now
and the only question is what are you
gonna do and I'll say that I said this
yesterday there was a young woman that I
was working with that had been sexually
molested and she was feeling really
guilty and damaged by it and I said to
her let me be clear
you have zero accountability for what
happened to you when you were eight and
nine years old zero don't feel guilty I
don't even care if you think back and
think I actually enjoyed it sometimes
and so you're thinking that makes me
different I feel guilty you have zero
accountability for what happened to you
when you were eight or nine you have
100% accountability for what you do
about it now as an adult you are
responsible what you do about it
is it fair that you have to be
responsible for it now that you have to
overcome that no it's not fair it just
is
I'm sorry that you have to deal with
that but you do and nobody can fix it
but you zero accountability then 100%
accountability now and so yeah I think
there is a problem that people don't
want that to be the case but it is the
case it did it's not it's not up to me
to say that this D is
sorry they just use say in the fields of
politics there's there's a tendency for
politicians to portray people's problems
as the result of vast impersonal forces
of which they are the victims and I
wonder if there's a tendency in the
field of psychology to paint people as
the victims of their own biology too
much to pathologize evil to essentially
suggest that decisions are not your own
so to take an example there's been a lot
of controversy over the last few weeks
over this documentary about Michael
Jackson who was allegedly a child
molester and they're several now I guess
for different kids who have come forward
now adults saying that he molested them
when they were children there was an
article by Dolly lilyc over it's late
that was kind of interesting in which
she said you know are we gonna treat
this as a sickness or we're gonna treat
this as though it's an evil is in other
words is Michael Jackson an evil man or
was he a man who is suffering from some
sort of biological sickness where do you
come down when it comes to determining
that balance in terms of personal
responsibility versus maybe genetic
drive to do something that we that we
think is evil or immoral well I can't
speak to the Michael Jackson situation
because I don't know the facts of that
situation but let's tell Carr
pathetically when you go into psychology
it's just like as an undergraduate you
have to pick an area of specialization
and for me it was clinical and that's
where you deal with neurosis psychosis
that's what you generally think of when
you think of going to a therapist
they're generally a clinical psychology
it's not always in the counseling and
others but generally it's clinical and
then I also completed the core in
behavioral medicine which is essentially
medical psychology it's the point at
which your physiology and your
psychology merge and interact and they
influence one another and that can be a
profound influence particularly with
chronic disease management and then when
I finished school I did a postdoctoral
fellowship in forensic psychology so now
I was dealing with psychology in the law
and one of the things that I was often
called on to do from a forensic
psychological standpoint is make a
determination between the irresistible
impulse
and the impulse not resisted and there's
just a few words to differentiate that
but it's often the difference between
the death penalty or life in prison and
going home an irresistible impulse you
become involuntary you're a passenger
this is an irresistible impulse you
could not resist this you're now a
passenger you're back in row 12 of the
bus an impulse not resisted you're
driving the bus you choose not to resist
this impulse and a big part of my
determination in those situations was
did this person have the capacity to
know the difference between right and
wrong and if someone is a pedophile if
they are aroused by children for example
okay clearly a deviant behavior right
unhealthy sickness no doubt about it do
they know the difference between right
and wrong do they know this is wrong but
they act on it anyway now to me if they
know it's wrong then they have the
ability to raise their hand and say I
have this problem I need help with this
I need controls built in around me for
this I need monitoring I need help with
this I have trouble with this and if
they fail to do that now I've got a
problem with their behavior but if they
say look I have a problem here and I
realized that I feel I don't want to
feel these things but I do and I know
it's wrong so I'm identifying myself I'm
going to mental health professionals I'm
identifying myself before I act on this
and there are many pedophiles that do
that by the way they do raise their hand
and say I this is they don't come out
publicly they go to the therapist and
say my god I'm
what is wrong with me and they get help
so somebody that feels that and knows
the difference between right and wrong
and one of the real simple ways to
figure that out is if they hide it
because if they hide it they must know
what's wrong so if they don't hide it
then they might not know what's wrong so
you can look at their behavior and see
did they go to great lengths to hide
this to cover this up if they do they
must know what's wrong so I was under
strong a couple of weeks ago and one of
the things we talked about was the
jussie Smollett alleged fake hate crime
and one of the topics that came up was
the possibility that we Americans may
value victimhood too highly we are all
sympathetic to victims who want to make
sure the victims are taken care of but
do you think that Americans are treating
victimhood as a sort of medal of honor
at this point well it depends if someone
is truly in an imbalance of power and
they are exploited I have great
compassion for that person but you have
to make a decision and maybe an
investigation to determine if that's
really the case or are they laying down
in front of the bus that they could both
get run over but did one of them go lay
down in front of the bus or was one
sitting in a cafe and the bus came over
the curb and ran over them they both got
run over by the bus but is there a
difference and to me there is a
difference it's a difference between
being a victim and a volunteer there are
victims that despite their best efforts
they are exploited and then there are
those who seem to volunteer for it and
take great pride in it and it becomes
their identity I have much less
compassion for those people and I think
there are some of those people and it
becomes who they are and they milk it
for everything they can and I'm not
talking about hoaxes one of the people
that truly become victimized in some way
they they get on the short end
of an imbalance of power but could sort
of change the subject for a miniature
place this is something that really
bothers me and you were on the show a
couple of weeks ago thank you very much
for doing that and you were on there
kind of as the sole voice on your side
of the issue with four or five other
voices that were kind of counterpoint
voices and I thought that we had a very
respectful intelligent conversation and
I talked to the audience afterwards in
studio I looked at the message boards
afterwards and I thought people on both
sides of the issue were a little bit
dumbstruck by what an intelligent
respectful exchange of ideas took place
even though there were some
diametrically opposed positions and I
walked backstage and you were back there
with a couple of those people that you
have debated before you are a hundred
and eighty degrees out from where they
are on positions and y'all were laughing
and talking and talking about some
personal issues and just really kind of
enjoying some personal time together
what has happened that that doesn't
happen anymore you were on different
sides of issues about is diametrically
opposed as you can get you said your
piece respectfully you didn't interrupt
anybody they didn't interrupt you
everybody it was a good conversation and
then y'all were backstage treating each
other like these are human beings what
happened to that why doesn't that happen
anymore
it happened you guys did it well again I
pin yin on this is that I do think that
there is currency and victimhood and
in public debate if you can claim that
you've somehow been harmed by the other
person then we grant you a sort of
patina of more credit or you're treated
with more respect so if you're in just
an honest debate and everybody's sort of
expected you know
understands the rules of the debate you
treat each other with respect somebody
wins somebody loses or maybe you just
have a discussion then there's no real
reward there but politically speaking I
think we live in a time where if you can
claim that that someone was mean to you
on stage or you claim that you were
offended by somebody that there is real
currency in that I was pointing this out
with regard to for example the vice
president Mike Pence and Joe Biden the
former vice president so a couple of
weeks ago Joe Biden did a speech in
Nebraska where he suggested that Mike
Pence was a decent guy and he was
immediately hit by a wave of people who
said well Mike minds isn't a decent guy
he disagrees with me on some LGBT issues
this would be Cynthia Nixon in the
former gubernatorial candidate New York
and Joe Biden then back down and then he
said well I guess Mike Pence isn't a
decent guy because we disagree on those
issues again I think that the reason
that he did that
is not because he doesn't actually think
pensa decent guy he knows Pence I think
that he probably thinks that's a decent
guy but if you can pretend that there is
a lack of character on the other side it
allows you to avoid having the kind of
productive discussions that that bring
unity and there's a lot of money to be
made and a lot of political hay to be
made in the polarization rather than in
the reasonable discussion I think well
here's what I think about that since you
asked you were gonna ask I could tell I
don't drink or smoke dope or take drugs
I never have because of my as I said I
made it
you know everybody makes decisions in
their lives like what we're gonna have
for lunch today where we're gonna go on
vacation but then there's another level
of the decision we make and I call those
life decisions life decisions you make
one time and that's it that's it for
your life like you make a decision
you're not gonna steal like so you make
that decision maybe in the third grade
you know when your parents tell you or
you get caught stealing or something so
you decide you're not gonna do that
anymore and that's a life decision I'm
not going to steal so you don't wake up
in the morning when you're thirty years
old and say oh man I'm in a rush and I'm
sure on cash do I want to go by the ATM
or knock over
7:11 you don't have that debate because
you've made a life decision I don't
steal so you're gonna go by the ATM
you're not gonna rob a 7-eleven and so
we make life decisions I made a life
decision early on that I wasn't gonna
drink or do drugs because of what I'd
seen it do to my dad who I thought was a
really good hard-working man I saw what
it did to him I don't have any problem
with people who do in moderation but one
of my best friends is Ron white the
blue-collar comedian now he smokes dope
every day and he drinks every day and
I've loaded him into the car and taking
him home and poured him out on the floor
before and people say how can these two
be friends you're mr. straight doesn't
do any of that and here's mr. never does
anything but that and my answer to that
is always the same you don't have to
love everything about somebody to love
them you don't have to love all their
behavior to love them I wish he didn't
do that but he does but he's also very
loyal he's a great father he's he's
really fun to be around he's an
intelligent guy interesting to talk to
very respectful of my wife and kids and
he's just a really great guy I don't
like this about him
but you don't have to like everything
about somebody to like them so why can
they not have a difference of opinion on
an issue and you still recognize they
have many redeeming qualities
if I if I had a brain tumor and the
surgeon that was coming in to save my
life had different political views but
this was the guy that could save my life
when I go no don't take this tumor out
of my head I don't like what you believe
politically hell no fix me I just don't
understand the intolerance that we now
seem to have
have for each other instead of
recognizing that we can differ on issues
and still recognize that there's
redeeming qualities in each other and I
don't say that politically I say it to
both sides of the aisle I just don't
understand it didn't seem to used to be
that way well I shouldn't ask you about
that in just one second but first
getting life insurance can feel like
assembling the world's worst jigsaw
puzzle it is confusing it takes forever
and when you're finally done it doesn't
even look cool but if you have a
mortgage kids anyone who depends on your
income it's a puzzle you need to solve
and policy genius can help you do it
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find the best policy for you when you
apply online the advisors and policy
genius will handle all the red tape
they'll even negotiate your rate with
the insurance company no commission
sales agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they also make it easy to find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance they are your
one-stop-shop for financial protection
so if you find life insurance puzzling
head on over to policy genius com in two
minutes you can compare quotes find the
right policy save up to 40% doing it
policy genius is the easy way to compare
and buy a life insurance be an adult I
know you don't want to think about death
or life insurance you should think about
it you should get it the best way to do
it go over to policy genius the easy way
to compare and buy life insurance go
check them out right now at policy
genius com so I want to ask you about
that you know you talked about how you
can love people without loving
everything about them and obviously
that's true there are really two
questions aren't asked about the first
one is in order to love person to love a
person does there have to be at least
some sense of shared values meaning that
you know that how much do you have to
love about the person in order for it to
be over the tipping point I'm not gonna
love somebody from al-qaeda or the
Taliban obviously I'm not gonna live in
neo Nazis it's gonna be very difficult
for me to to love those people and it's
not just a political disagreement their
root values that are that are in
disagreement what root values do you
think that people need to share in order
for there to be a bedrock for love to
grow well I think that you've you've
just identified it it's root values I
mean I'm not gonna hang out with Hitler
cuz he plays a hell of a game of golf I
could give about his game of golf right
I mean everything about
is offensive to my sensibilities so that
is overwhelmingly we are just different
people with different core values and
that's not what I'm talking about if
you're talking about somebody from
al-qaeda if you're talking about
somebody that is a child molester and
the I mean just everything they stand
for is offensive to your sensibilities
the gap is too wide you can't get a
bridge to span that but that's generally
not the case if you sit down with people
you know it for example if I'm if I'm
negotiating with people whether it's a
business deal I'm negotiating or if I'm
trying to broker a peace between a
couple that is really at odds with each
other and on the brink of divorce I
always do the same thing I say but first
let's talk about what we agree about now
I know you came here to resolve your
differences but first I want to make a
list of what we agree about because if
we do that we might just find that what
we disagree about is less than we
realize so let's talk about what we
agree about and we make that list and if
that list is really small then maybe
that gap is too wide
but if that risk if that list is made up
of those root values and core values
like you know we both want our children
to do well you know we both love these
kids
we both want certain things you have a
good list of root values and then you
look at what we disagree about and you
realize well maybe we have different
currencies here maybe I can give you
more of what you want you give me more
of what I want because you value
something more than I do and I value
something more than you do I I'm willing
this is a one for me and a ten for you I
can give you that and that's a two for
you and a ten for me
so it's an easy gift for you but a big
gift for me if you get people
where they're looking for ways to come
together instead of looking for ways to
come apart then you can begin to make
some headway and that's all I'm saying
we don't seem to have a dialogue well
and I think that that's what I'm getting
to is I think that the incentive
structure is is aligned so much right
now politically for people to make gains
with their own side by drawing
distinction so you're saying that you
know you draw points of unity and that's
how you got together but politics isn't
about how you draw together politics
right now at least is about how you draw
a distinction with the other side so
that you convince people to come to your
side and the easiest way to do that is
to attack them on a character level not
on a policy level if you admit that the
other side is basically good-hearted has
good intentions that they mainly want
good things even if we disagree about
how to get there well then people might
side with that person but if you say
that that person is a racist sexist pig
at homophobe if you say that person is a
Nazi if you say that person has no
tolerance then it's a lot easier to get
people to side with you after all what
are they gonna do side with this person
who you just characterized as Hitler so
it's an easy it's an easy political game
it's one I really object to and in a
strong way but I think that that's I
think that's the the easiest political
currency out there right now yeah and
what I really find offensive is when you
see people backstage that treat each
other with dignity and respect and then
walk out on stage and put on a
completely different persona that is
really hypocritical and disingenuous to
me now I don't trust either one of them
yeah totally agree with that so I want
to ask you about changing people so you
know that that's sort of the second
question is you're talking about shared
values is there you've said before that
you think people change but does that
mean that you can change them or does it
have to be an internally driven thing
because so much of politics and life is
about determining whether you ought to
accept someone for the flaws that they
have or whether you ought to expend
effort in the attempt to change them so
take for example your friend was there a
certain point where you said you know
what we have given him a lecture 20
times about not drinking and not doing
drugs he's not doing it I can either
take him as he is or I can leave him
when do you make that call as to whether
somebody is changeable or not well I
think when you disagree the gold knee
to be that you're heard and understood
not that you win and in certainly I
think that's true at a personal level if
you're in a relationship certainly if
it's a husband and wife and your goal is
to win what does that mean
that means that your partner is now a
loser and when people lose how do they
feel they feel like a loser
they feel like they lost do you want
your husband or wife to feel like a
loser why would you want that if instead
you say look all right my goal here is
I'm gonna I want you to hear me I want
you to understand me and then I'll shut
up and across time if if you proved to
be sensitive to that and you try to find
some middle ground with me and I try to
find some middle ground with you then
this relationship is going to have a
long-term history if not then maybe it
won't but my goal is not gonna be to
grind you down where you finally say
okay okay you're right you're right
you're right
you got it aside if you want to be right
or you want to be happy and being right
comes with a lot of resentment from
those that you've proven wrong and that
doesn't seem to advance personal agendas
or political agendas I mean and that's
really the question is is there a
difference between personal interactions
and political interactions in the sense
that when it comes to political
interactions there is an actual result
that is apart from the two sides meaning
that there will be a law for example or
there will be a public policy that at
the end of the day is promulgated I mean
my marriage my goal is to preserve the
marriage because I married a person with
whom I share values the marriage is more
important than anything else that is on
the table and that means that I'm
willing to subsume fact in favor of
feeling when it comes to my wife this is
for my parents and my siblings but when
it comes to politics where you're
determining the rules that govern the
society or how we ought to see reality
itself in some cases what should be the
mix there between facts and and feelings
well yeah I think that people say
politics are local not national I
disagree with that I think politics are
personal I don't think they're local I
think they're personal that people can
deny that but I think people sit down
and say what's in this for me
how's this gonna affect my family how's
this gonna affect me whether it's a law
about taxes or whatever how is if
something's going to change the mix of
the community or it's going to change
laws about how long you work or
retirement or taxation whatever people
may not want to say it but I think they
look at it and say you know how is this
going to affect me and so I think it
gets down very much like a relationship
I think they look at it in terms of its
personal impact and once they decide
that they can live with whatever that
outcome is then they start to think
about others you know it's first it's
survival then its actualization then you
start you gotta take you got to survive
first and then you can start caring for
others and taking care of them and I'm
not saying that people don't have
genuine empathy and concern for others
but I I guess the thing that I would
really want people to do I believe
knowledge is power
I think knowing the true unspun facts of
a situation are critically important and
I'm just not sure that many people have
access to that in this day and time I
don't know where to get unspun news
today I don't know where to get it yeah
I'm not sure that it's that it's even
possible I mean I think they're people
who are striving for it but I think
everybody has their own cognitive biases
that act themselves out in real time and
no matter how we discuss the issues when
it comes to the definite the different
between personal political I'll give an
example of where I think that for
example there's a gap so on the issue of
transgenderism I've been very outspoken
I think that a biological man is a
biological man I think a biological
woman is a biological woman there are
people who are intersex but that does
not obviate the categories of male and
female I do not think that a man can
become a woman or a woman can become a
man and if a man wants to identify as a
woman I think that that is factually
incorrect my view of that is that that's
a mental disorder now if I'm at dinner
with a person who is transgender I will
call them by their preferred pronoun
because what's the point in defending
the person the person is still a person
I wouldn't go out of my way to insult
somebody who I'm at dinner with but if
I'm speaking publicly about Caitlyn
Jenner for example I will say the
Caitlyn Jenner is a man and I will call
him by his biological pronouns the
reason for that is because in the dinner
situation my target audience is the
person with whom I'm speaking that's the
person with whom I'm forming a
relationship in the political world the
target audience is not Caitlyn Jenner on
speaking to Caitlyn Jenner I'm speaking
to the audience were large about a
scientific issue that has some
ramifications for for Public Policy I'm
not sure how to bridge that gap when
people suggest that we ought to discuss
public policy as though it were personal
we should obably we should pretend that
scientific facts don't exist in order to
not offend for example well I think what
you're talking about is the difference
between being genuine and being brutally
honest there is a time in a place for
everything and the time in the place for
you to air your scientific based
political agenda doesn't have to be at
dinners I mean there's a time where that
fits and there's a time where you're in
that mode and you could say what you
want but is that appropriate at dinner
and if you feel uncomfortable with not
being consistent with your scientific
belief then don't get in that situation
but it's kinda like my wife tells me at
home don't you dr. Phil me
you do that at home don't you do that
don't you do that here you know there's
a time and a place for everything and I
think you're I think you've chosen very
well to say I'm not going to be
offensive to this person's belief system
here but you put me in a public forum
and ask me to take a position I'm gonna
do what I'm gonna be true to my belief
system here that doesn't mean I have to
be offensive to this person's belief
system there so in a second I want to
ask you about your religious worldview
because religion is obviously a great
part of how people become happy in
certain social science studies I'm gonna
ask you what your factors are for
happiness how do you become a happy
person and does religion play a part in
that but first let's talk about your
emergency food storage wise company
freeze-dried food it's easy to prepare
it can be stored for up to 25 years
you're going to have the peace of mind
that comes with being prepared with food
in case of an emergency there are lots
of types of emergencies for which you
might need freeze-dried emergency food
hurricanes tornadoes earthquakes floods
wildfires power outages job loss wise
company takes an innovative approach and
providing dependable simple affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use when
government resources are strained it
could be days if not weeks before you
can get to fresh food in water you can't
rely on somebody else you have to rely
on yourself this week my listeners can
get any wise emergency or outdoor food
products and an extra 25% off the lowest
market price at wise food storage comm /
apparel plus shipping is free Wise has a
90 day no questions asked return policy
so there's no risk in taking the
initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today that is wise
food storage calm / Shapiro to get any
wise emergency or outdoor food product
had an extra 25% off plus free shipping
that's wise food storage calm / Shapiro
so let's talk a little bit about how to
become a happy person so there's a lot
of focus on happiness particularly in
Western civilization the traditional
religious worldview has been your
happiness is of no consequence basically
that you have duty and duty is what
motivates you and if you fill your duty
then you'll be happy and the typical
sort of Aristotelian view if you act in
accordance with virtue you'll be happy
we in Western society think to seem to
think that happiness is sometimes
material goods sometimes it is you know
kind of the joy of the moment how do you
define happiness and what you
we be aiming for yeah well a friend of
mine there's a poster that says money
won't buy happiness but it'll get you
where it is should get you real close to
where it is you know I think it's very
individual and and I think it comes down
not only to how you define it but how
you experience and express it I mean
because happiness is not just a
definition it's experiential I mean
let's put on our gestalt hats for a
minute and say what's our experiential
happiness and you know to me I start
using synonyms like fulfillment and
peace and joy and you know I'm I'm what
my wife Robin calls emotionally
constricted sometimes I mean something
good will happen and you know she's
looks like you know Snoopy dancing in
the peanuts cartoon you know and she
looks at me and says give me something
come on give me something here and I
might be feeling all warm inside and and
it's like okay I've achieved that I've
clicked that off I'm I feel great about
this and you know for me happiness is is
a real sense of peace and accomplishment
and and that kind of sense of of having
climbed this mountain and done that and
and I'm I'm very happy about that but I
may not be as expressive as she is or
the next person is and I think it's
different I think it's different for
everybody and for some people they
define that with you know spiritual
awakenings and spiritual evolution some
people achieve it through a sense that
they're really being altruistic in some
way some people just
materialistically and i think it changes
as we change things make me what i call
happy or fulfilled now that didn't have
that effect on me 30 years ago I've got
this this kind of ruler that I've made I
roll it out on the floor and it goes
from zero to 83 which is the life
expectancy and I have people sometimes
walk along and it stand on their age and
when I walk along it and stand on my age
and look over my shoulder there's a
whole lot of white behind me and not
very much ahead of me so now having good
health and being able to enjoy what's
around me now my my kids who are grown
and my grandkids I mean to me spending
time with them and having the health and
and cognition to enjoy it that to me is
really fulfillment and happiness and and
that to me really fills me up thirty
years ago
I took most of that for granted so it
didn't have an effect on me so I think
it changes across time and I know now
one of the things that gives me the most
fulfillment is I love giving a voice to
people that don't have it so I'm working
on us with a story on dr. Phil that has
children caught in the crossfire
in a custody battle or something and
they're just being torn apart and used
as a rope in a tug-of-war and I could
come in and stop that and get these kids
out of this crossfire and give them the
voice they don't have I might go home
tired that night but it's a good tired I
feel good about what I've done this was
a good thing and if millions of people
watch that and a percentage of them
won't do that because they saw the pain
in these kids eyes and I realize I've
impacted those people then that's a good
time
the end of the day and that's a joy for
me so you know sometimes it's it's tied
to achievement sometimes it's it's tied
to something else but I think it has a
lot to do with peace and fulfillment so
I want to ask you about something that
seems to be making a lot of people
deeply unhappy and that is social media
do you think that social media is a net
benefit or a net detriment to human
beings were we ready for this machine
that we created for ourselves and I'm
talking from the perspective of someone
who's extraordinarily active on Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter and all the
rest but the science tends to suggest
that this stuff may not be particularly
good for us where do you come down on
the social media well I think we have to
it's here so where I come down on it is
deal with it because it's here here's
what I think and you know when I started
dr. Phil the first text message had not
been sent there was no Twitter there was
no Facebook there were no smartphones so
I'm dealing with things now that didn't
even exist when I started but I'm also
dealing with kids who used to come home
and their mother said sit down
you can't talk right now dr. Phil's on
now they're coming on to the show and
their kids are saying they're saying hey
can't talk right now dr. Phil's on and I
realize that we have a whole new set of
influences on kids and they have access
to information that I didn't have when I
was growing up that's racing them along
the evolutionary continuum in terms of
relationships and emotion and they are
access to bullies and predators and all
that we didn't have to deal with in my
generation if you were getting bullied
at school you went home it stopped now
you go home the cyber bullies just
follow you home and you get online and
they're bullying you at home so it's
here we have to deal with it I was
invited to testify on Capitol Hill on
the reauthorization of the Elementary
and Secondary Education Act
and they were asking should they
allocate money to the curriculum to deal
with cyberbullying and I was there to
say not this yes but hell yes because
teachers were saying it doesn't happen
on campus so we don't it's not our job
and I was saying it both it is your job
because these are the kids that are
doing it and you're watching these kids
throughout the day what we have to start
doing is preparing our children to deal
with the social media world because if
we have a generation that grows up with
the need to be loved by strangers we're
creating a a a vulnerable generation
that is giving their power away to
people they don't even know if your mood
is driven by how many likes a picture
you post is that I've talked to kids
that they'll put up a picture and it
doesn't get 10 percent of the likes the
last one did and their moods to cycle
down I've talked to parents whose kids
were cyber bullied to death we hate you
go kill yourself and they walk in and
their daughters hung themselves in the
closet and they're dead and they go look
at their social media and there's 75
posts there just kill yourself we don't
want to see you tomorrow we we have to
prepare our children to realize this is
not the World Wide Web it's the wild
wild web there's no control there's no
enforcement there's no accountability so
we have to inoculate our kids so they
realize this isn't the real world these
are keyboard bullies they wouldn't say
that to you in the elevator but they'll
say it to you with the anonymity of the
keyboard sharing the bleed-over meaning
that you know there's always been this
sort of feeling on twitter or facebook
that there's the online world and then
there's the real world and the online
world is not real and when you turn off
the computer life gets better but what
I'm starting to see is that the crudity
of the online world is bleeding over
into the real world people are treating
each other worse in the real world as a
result of them being accustomed to treat
each other badly online I hope not
I mean I haven't seen any research about
that but I'm seeing it get worse online
and I'm saying just this last weekend a
few weekends ago sorry I flew into North
Carolina to meet with the family of
Shannon Watts who Kris Watts the family
Annihilator that killed his wife and two
babies Bella and CeCe
you would call that story he's just he
had just given a real confession about
what he actually did in killing her and
those two children and the family wanted
to sit down and talk and I went in and
sat down and talked with Susan and Frank
and Frankie jr. her brother and one of
the biggest problems they have in their
grief right now are the internet trolls
there are trolls that are opening
accounts in their daughter's name and
sending messages like so they get up and
get on the internet and there's a
message from their daughter Shannon that
says I'm burning in hell why did you do
this to me things like that just to
torture them and trolls accusing them of
things and saying they are the real
murderers and all just just stuff of
people that they're just pure sick evil
people and you know that wouldn't happen
if there wasn't social media so that's a
real downside to it and there's there's
no enforcement of that and there's got
to be some way to find those people and
hold them accountable for that because
you know some people that don't react
well to that it can actually push them
over the edge and be suicidal so some of
it is out of control and I don't know
what the answer is but it is out of
control so when it comes to how to train
your kids for this or
stuff you deal with kids on a regular
basis on the show what are sort of the
rules for the road in teaching your kids
how to deal with the world that seems
like it's it may be increasingly chaotic
well you have to talk to them about it
number one look kids have the knowledge
but not the wisdom to handle this
Internet in the world wide web adults
have the wisdom but not the knowledge
those kids can navigate around there my
god with three clicks they can have you
anywhere in anything looking at whatever
you know we're in there trying to figure
out how to get this camera to point the
other way for thirty minutes and by then
you know they've gone around the world
so they've got the knowledge we need to
provide the wisdom and you've got to sit
down and talk to them and you remember
well you're too young but there used to
be these ads that would come on at ten
o'clock at night they would say it's 10
o'clock do you know where your children
are do you remember those no before my
time I used to be just come out ten
o'clock in this drill being it's ten
o'clock do you know where your kids are
with the internet it's always 10 o'clock
you need to know where your kids are and
parents need to find out what platforms
their kids are going to and they say
well I don't want to invade their
privacy my advice
invade their privacy get a screen name
get in that that group see if your
child's being groomed they may not
notice it but you need to notice it see
if somebody's talking trying to get your
daughter out the bedroom window and she
thinks it's another 13 year old and it's
really a 40 year old pedophile predator
out there you need to monitor you need
to know where they're going and you need
to talk to them and show when it when an
article is in the paper about someone
being abducted by somebody they met you
need to show them I'm not trying to make
them paranoid or make them think the
world is a scary place but they need to
be situationally aware you need to talk
to them about that and if they become
obsessed then you need to get them to
unplug and if they're spending if all
you ever see is the top of their head
and their thumbs are going like this you
need to limit the time that they're on
there
and you can put child controls on there
but they'll defeat those before you set
them up you need to limit their time
and you need to know where they're going
and you and you need to monitor that so
you can protect them from themselves
from those from others so I have one
final question for you you've done 3000
shows don't ask if there's one
particular episode that sticks out to
you but first if you want to hear dr.
Phil's answer you have to be a daily
wire subscriber to subscribe head on
over to daily wire comm click Subscribe
and you can hear the end of our
conversation there
well dr. Phil thanks so much for
stopping by folks you need to check out
dr. Phil's podcast it's called fill in
the blanks go check it out right now of
course everybody watches your show so I
don't even need to plug dr. Phil that's
just I mean everyone knows about it
thanks so much for stopping by really
appreciate your time thanks so much
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan case hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia and Guillot the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]